So the Coral key-based routing takes a different approach. In the Coral
key-based routing, rather than being greedy,
we are going to slowly progress towards
our desired destination. In particular, I mentioned that the distance between
two nodes in the node namespace is given by the XOR of the node IDs.
So, in particular, if I look at the source 14 here, and the destination four
here, we can compute the XOR distance between the source and the
desired destination. And the routing table now
is populated with numbers. And what these
numbers show is the XOR distance from
any particular node to the desired destination.
So, the XOR distance from my source, which is 14, to
the destination, which is four, is ten. The XOR distance from the node whose ID
is 13 and the destination is four is nine. And similarly, the
XOR distance from the node whose ID is five and the destination four, is one.
So what I have now in my routing table
is the XOR distance of the desired destination.
That's what I have in this entry of this routing table
that says what is the XOR distance for my desired destination right now from
each of the guys that I know how to get to directly? I know
how to get to 13. I know how to get
to three, and two, and zero, and five. And what
I am looking at now is if I get to
13, what is the distance of that guy from the desired
destination? What is the distance of this guy from the
desired destination and so on? That's what these table entries
are showing right now. These are the nodes that are
directly reachable from me. And what they showing is the XOR
distance of each of the nodes that are
directly reachable from me to the desired destination. So
in Coral, what we are going to do is in each hop I'm going to go to some
node that is half the distance to the
destination in the node ID namespace. Recall in the
greedy approach since I have a way of getting
to node number five, I directly went to him
with the hope that he'll get me to my desired
destination. Not so in Coral key-based routing. What we're going
to do is in each hop we're going to go
to some node that is half the distance to the
destination in the node ID namespace. Now the XOR distance
between the source and the destination, 14 and 4, is
ten. So in the first hop I'll go to the
node that is half the distance to my desired destination,
desired destination being ten. I want to go to a node, number five. Second hop,
I want to go to a node that is half the distance of five. That is two distant
from the desired destination. And third hop I want to go to a node that is
one distant. That is, finally I am home.
So that's the idea behind the Coral key-based routing.
But of course, when I have a particular distance metric, like ten in this case,
and I want to go half the distance in the first hop I may not
have a direct way of reaching the guy who is half the distance to the
desired node. So let's see how actually
Coral key-based routing works, given this particular example.